السلام عليكم دعا الشيخ سالم الرفاعي
الشباب من سنه لبنان للجهز التامه
استعدادا لارسالهم الى سوريا دفاعا عن
ابناء طائفتهم في منطقه القصير السوريه
دعوه الرفاعي جاءت في م قال ردا بالمثل
على تدخل حزب الله في القتال الدائري هناك
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنقاش في
محورين خلفيات وحجم التدخل الميداني لحزب
الله في القتال داخل
سوريا وفرص لبنان في تلف مزيد من التورط
في الازمه السوريه على ضوء هذا
التدخل
تدخل حزب الله في القتال الدائر في منطقه
الاقصر السوريه فجاءت ردود الفعل سريعه من
قيادات سنيه لبنانيه قائلين مثلا او مثلا
بمثل كما ارسل حزب الله مقاتليه لنصره
الشيعه في سوريا يحق لنا ان نرسل من يحمي
السنه هناك موقف تجاوز الكلام الى الفعل
بالشروع في اعداد المقاتلين لارسالهم الى
سوريا منذرا باندلاع ما بات يعرف في بلاد
الارز بحروب سوريا في
لبنان
هل ولا زمن سياسه الناي بالنفس في لبنان
بشان الازمه السوريه جبهه الحدود بين
البلدين مشتعله رسميا منذ نحو اسبوعين
صواريخ تسقط وقصف من مسلحي المعارضه
السوريه على بلدات وقرا على التراب
اللبناني في الهرمل والقصر ومن قبل عكار
وعرسال يحمل كل طرف الاخر مسؤوليه التصعيد
الاخير في بلد لم يتعافى من حرب اهليه
انتهت منذ سنوات طويله يعتبر حزب الله
اللبناني الذي بات طرفا في الصراع الدامي
دوره في معارك حمص الى جانب الجيش النظامي
في سوريا واجبا وطنيا لحمايه اللبنانيين
في القرى الحدوديه يبرر المسلحون في سوريا
قصفهم لمناطق لبنانيه ومنها اهداف سكنيه
بانه رد على مشاركه عناصر حزب الله في
المعارك التي يخوضها الجيش النظامي
لاستعاده السيطره على القصير ومناطق اخرى
في حمص وبغض الطرف عن وجهه نظر كل ط فان
تصدير الصراع الى لبنان سيكون كارثيا على
المنطقه برمتها التطورات الاخيره لا تبشر
بخير شيخان لبنانيان سلفيانا وسالم
الرافعي يصدران فتاوى ان وجدت لها اصداء
فسيتعين يعلن احمد الاسير تاسيس ما يسميها
كتائب المقاومه الحره للجهاد في سوريا
ومجموعات سريه صغيره للدفاع عن النفس اما
سالم الرافعي فقد بالتعبئه العامه في صفوف
اهل السنه لنصره اللبنانيين السنه في
القصير وكانه يراد للحرب السوريه في حال
تصديرها الى لبنان ان تكون حربا طائفيه
سنيه شيعيه تستغل اكثر من جهه داخليه
وخارجيه في لبنان الخلافات المستمره بين
السياسيين والوضع الامني الهاش والاحتقان
الطائفي الذي يتصاعد تاره ويخف تاره اخرى
لتنفيذ
اجندتها الشعب اللبناني امام امتحان صعب
اما الانزلاق في عنف سيكون اقصى من سنوات
الحرب الاهليه او مواجهه جميع من يسعون
الى جعله ساحه لتصفيه حسابات دول اخرى
لبنان بحاجه الى مصالحه حقيقيه بين جميع
ابنائه وليس الى فتنه اخرى ستضر بكل
اللبنانيين دون
استثناء موضوع الحلقه نناقشه مع ضيفين من
طرابلس الشيخ سالم الرافعي نائب رئيس هيئه
علماء المسلمين في لبنان ومن بيروت الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السيد فيصل عبد الساتر
مرحبا بكما الشيخ سالم الرفاعي ما
المعلومات او الشيخ سالم الرافعي عفوا ما
المعلومات التي توفرت لديكم وعلى اساسها
اتخذتم هذا القرار ودعوت هذه
الدعوه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين اخي الكريم الحكومه
اللبنانيه اتخذت سياسه النائب النفس ونحن
نعلم انه من فتره بعيده
حزب الله يرسل مقاتليه الى سوريا للدفاع
عن نظام المجرم بشار الاسد لكن هذا الامر
لم يتجلى او لم يظهر عيانا
للناس حتى اعلن حزب الله انه يرسل جنوده
والياته هناك للدفاع عن اللبنانيين الشيعه
في سوريا وعن المقامات الدينيه هناك وصار
يشيع جنازات مقاتليه علنا امام كل الناس
وحتى المسؤولون السياسيون يشيعون هذه
الجنازات وحتى وصل الامر الى ان الان ما
يجري في لقصي من معارك نستطيع ان نقول ان
الجيش النظامي السوري لا دخل له فيها انما
يتولاها حزب الله قياده وتخطيطا وجنودا
وتنفيذا فالامر وصل الى حد خطير اليوم
يقتل الالاف من اخواننا السوريين واخواتنا
تغتصب نسمع كيف تذبح الاطفال وانت النساء
لذلك هذا الامر وصل الى حد خطير الدوله لم
تستطع ان تفعل شيئا ترى حزب الله وهو يرسل
الياته وينصب بطاريات صواريخه في الهرمل
وفي البقاع ويقصف اهلنا في القصير
وغيرهم دوله لا تفعل ش هل اجريت تقييما
للمكاسب والخسائر التي يمكن ان تترتب على
قرار او دعوه كهذه يعني هل هل سوريا تعاني
من نقص في المقاتلين الذين يحملون الجنسيه
السوريه حتى تدعو او حتى تدعو الى ارسال
مقات قلين اجانب
لها يا اخي الكريم اخواتنا واخواننا في
سوريا طلبوا منا النصره النساء والاطفال
والشيوخ طلبوا منا نصرتنا فهذا واجب ديني
شرعي انساني اخلاقي لا يجوز لنا ان نتخلف
عنه الامر الثاني حزب الله لا ينتظر في
قضيه او نقل الفتنه الى لبنان حزب الله لا
ينتظر سببا من يدعي ان هذا هو السبب او قد
يكون سببا ل الفتنه الى لبنان حزب الله لا
ينتظر سببا فلما اجتاحوا بيروت سنه 2008
في سبع ايار لم يكن هناك سبب
وجيه الامر الثاني اذا كان حزب الله
بالعلن يقاتل اخواننا سواء لبنانيين ولا
السوريين السنه في سوريا هذا ايضا سيستجيب
نان الى مشاكل كثيره قد يقوم الجيش الحر
وهو يقوم بقصف الكرى اللبنانيه وتشريد
الناس ويقوم ايضا بتشريد من الشيعه الذين
لا يهتمون بسيد حزب الله وقد لا يؤيدونه
فاذا شعر اخواننا السوريون بان اهل السنه
في لبنان لم ينصروه كما يفعل حزب الله
ينصر شيعته وجماعته فسوف يقصفون الكره
كلها فنحن بخروج فيصل عبد الساتر سيد فيصل
عبد الساتر دائما ما كان يردد حزب الله ان
البندقيه لا توجه الا للمحتل الصهيوني
وذلك في معرض دفاعه عن احتفاظه بسلاحه
وبالتالي احتفاظه بوضعيه مميزه مميزه داخل
الدوله اللبنانيه ذات الهياكل والمؤسسات
والجيش والحكومه وغيرها حتى انه بدا وكانه
يتصرف كدوله داخل الدوله في كثير من
المناسبات ما بال هذه البندقيه تم التساهل
في الهدف الذي توجه اليه فاصبحت توجه الى
صدور السوريين في القتال الدائر على
الاراضي السوريه ثم ها هي بعد دعوه كهذه
يمكن ان توجه الى لبنانيين هل يعي حزب
الله المخاطر التي يمكن ان تترتب على
الداخل اللبناني من جراء خطوات كهذه
اولا لنعد الى يعني الاسباب الموضوعيه
والرئيسيه
للازمه التي تحدث حاليا بسبب ما يقولون
انه تدخل لحزب الله في بعض الاراضي
اللبنانيه السوريه في الازمه السوريه اولا
دعنا نتحدث اولا هي لم تكن الاسباب الاولى
لاستجرار الازمه السوريه الى الداخل
اللبناني لقد فعلت المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه الكثير من الاعتداءات على الداخل
اللبناني وعلى كثير من الافرقاء في الداخل
اللبناني ولم يتحدث احد عن هذا الموضوع لا
بالاعلام ولا باي وسيله من الوسائل ثم
الحكومه اللبنانيه كانت دائما تقول انها
ترفع شعار النائي بالنفس وبالتالي كان
هناك معسكرات تدريب ترسل المقاتلين من
الشمال ومن جرود عرسال الى داخل الاراضي
السوريه ولم يتحرك احد في الداخل اللبناني
ويقول ونصره الشعب السوري او لنصره الشعب
السوري الان عندما بدات الازمه ما تقترب
من داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه وتحديدا من
مدينه الهرمل التي تشكل خزانا استراتيجيا
للمقاومه وعندما بدا بالاعتداء الممنهج
لتهجير الاهالي اللبنانيين والذين هم يعني
ينتمون الى مختلف الطوائف يعني ليس
الموضوع موضوع شيعه لم يقل حزب الله انه
يدافع عن الشيعه قال حزب الله انه يدافع
عن اهلنا اللبنانيين في تلك المناطق وهذه
المناطق موجود فيها علويين ومرشدين وسنه
وشيعه ومسيحيين يعني لم يقل انه يدافع عن
القريه الشيعيه دون القريه السنيه في هذا
اللسان الذي يسمى لسان غرب نهر العاصي في
تلك المنطقه والذي يمتد الى منطقه القصير
لكن عندما اصبح الخطر داهم وعندما اصبح
العدد يعني عدد المهجرين وعدد الذين
يقتلون في هذه البلدات عددا لا يحتمل
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يعني الوقوف مكتوفي
الايدي امام هذا الموضوع السؤال لسماحه
الشيخ سالم عندما يقول انه هب لنصره
اخوانه من السنه في القصير هل المطلوب
مذهبه الصراع في سوريا هل المطلوب تطييف
الصراع في سوريا هل المطلوب تديين الصراع
في المنطقه هناك صراع على خلفيه قبل طرح
هذه الاسئله يعني انا انا فقط اريد ان
استوضح منك شي انت تريد ان تقول لحظه لحظه
لحظه انت تريد ان تقول ان تدخل حزب الله
في هذا الصراع جاء تاليا على اعتداءات
قامت بها عناصر مسلحه من الداخل السوري
على الاراضي اللبنانيه لاحدهم ان يسال اين
اين الدوله اللبنانيه من هذا ولا يحق
للدوله اللبنانيه ان تتدخل هي لضر المفاسد
التي يمكن ان تقع على طائفه من ابنائها
بدلا من ان يتدخل في ذلك فصيل سياسي في
الداخل
اللبناني هذا سؤال برسم الدوله اللبنانيه
لكن دعني اتحدث عن الجغرافيا وهنا
الجغرافيا تلعب دورا خطيرا في هذا الموضوع
نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 20 قريه هي داخل
الاراضي السوريه جغرافيا وقضاء ئيا هي
تتبع لريف القصير او لقضاء القصير بحسب
السجلات الموجوده لدى الدوائر القضائيه او
الدوائر العدليه في منطقه القصير يقولون
ان هناك 20 ال نسمه تسكن في هذه القرى
والبلدات وهي قرى وبلدات معظمها الكاسح
والغالب من اللبنانيين من جميع الطوائف لا
تستطيع الدوله اللبنانيه ان تخرق الحدود
المتعارف عليها بين لبنان وسوريا لان هناك
ك اتفاقيات وان هناك يعني امورا صعبه على
المستوى الميداني وعلى المستوى العسكري
لذلك قام الاهالي الذين ينتمون الى
تنظيمات لبنانيه بطبيعه الحال منهم حزب
الله ومنهم حركه امل منهم من هو الحزب
السوري القومي من هو من هو بحزب البعث
منهم من لديه الجنسيه السوريه فقاموا
بتشكيل لجان شعبيه وهذه اللجان الشعبيه
كان مهمتها الحفاظ على هذه القرى والبلدات
منذ اكثر من سته اشهر عند عندما لم تستطع
هذه اللجان الشعبيه ارسل اليها عدد من
المقاتلين الذين ينتمون الى هذه العائلات
وبالتالي هم منتمون الى الاحزاب المدربه
عسكريا لكن هم من ابناء هذه المنطقه
ويمتون بصله القرابه لهذه المنطقه قاموا
بالدفاع عن هذه القرى والبلدات ليس هناك
مره اخرى سيد فيصل ما فهمناه من هذه
المداخله ان تدخل حزب الله جاء تاليا على
اعتداءات نفذها عناصر مسلح من الاراضي
السوريه كيف تردون على هذا الشيخ سالم
الرافعي دعني اوضح دعني اوضح ليس هناك
تدخل ل هناك تدخل للجان شعبيه وافراد
ينتمون الى احزاب لبنانيه منهم حزب الله
طيب سيد
سالم اخي الكريم الكل يعلم
بان التدخل السوري او قصف المجاهدين
السوريين للكره اللبنانيه جاء بعد تدخل
حزب الله في الداخل السوري اقول ايضا
للناس لا يجوز ان نخدع يخدع بعضنا بعضا
كلنا نعلم ما يجري في سوريا ان حزب الله
ينفذ اجنده ايران في المنطقه وهو ان
يسيطروا على تلك البلاد وتكون هناك دوله
طائفيه هذا ايضا مشروع يخدم اسرائيل اذا
اردنا ان نخدع الناس نقول نحن ندافع او
حزب الله يدافع عن لبنانيين على الحدود
نحن ايضا نقول لكم ارسلنا شبابنا ليدافعوا
عن لبنانيين اخرين ايضا يقتلون في القصير
وريفها وفي تلكلخ وندافع عن اعراضهم
ونسائهم الاصل ان يترك هذا الدفاع للدوله
اللبنانيه هي الدوله المسؤوله عن الدفاع
عن اللبنانيين سواء من هذا الطرف او من
ذاك الطرف لا ان يقوم احد ان يتولى هذه
المسؤوليه هذا طعم بسياده الدوله سيد فيصل
عبد الساتر اثار نقطه بالغه الاهميه هل
ترون ان من الحكمه مذهبه الصراع على هذا
النحو انتم ترفعون شعار الدفاع عن سنه
سوريا من الاشقاء الموجودين على الاراضي
السوريه يعني حتى حتى حزب الله عندما تدخل
في هذا الامر لم يذكر الطوائف ولم يذكر
الشيعه ولا
غيرهم اخي انا على ما اذكر ورد في كلام
السياسيين او بعض السياسيين من حزب الله
انهم يدافعون عن اللبنانيين الشيعه هذه
المساله الاولى المساله الثانيه لا نريد
ان نختبئ وراء اصابعنا هناك صراع مذهبي
قائم في المنطقه كلها ايران تؤجل هذا
الصراع لا مصلحه لنا في هذا الصراع نحن لا
نحارب الشيعه كشي نحن نحارب مشروع ايران
في المنطقه نحارب حزب الله الذي يريد ان
يعتدي على اهلنا سواء في بيروت ولا في
سوريا سواء كانوا لبنانيين ام سوريين نحو
لا ننظر اخي الكريم الى كثير هذه الحسابات
حسابات السياسيين واعتباراته نسمع النات
النساء وهي تغتصب نسمع صارخ الاطفال وهم
يذبحون لا يهمون من كان الذابح هو شبيحه
الاسد ام من حزب الله ام من القوميين
السوريين عندما تقول عندما تقول ن نحارب
حزب الله وكيل المشروع الايراني او هكذا
يعني حول هذا المعنى طوفت في كلامك الا
تخشى من انتقال هذه الحرب من الاراضي
السوريه الى الاراضي اللبنانيه هل لبنان
تنقصه اثاره لمثل هذه النعرات في اللحظه
التاريخيه الحساسه التي يمر بها
يا اخي الكريم النظام السوري من اول
الاحداث الجاريه في سوريا حاول نقل السراء
الى لبنان من خلال مشروع ميشيل سماحه
المعروف وايضا من خلال قتل الناشطين
اللبنانيين في الثوره السوريه ك الشيخان
في عكار وخالد الحميد في ارسال وايضا من
خلال مشاريع كثيره حاول النظام السوري نقل
الفتنه الى لبن من خلال ضرب جبل محسن
مرارا وتكرارا لاهلنا في التبانه حاولنا
اطفاء هذه الفتنه قدر الامكان ولكن انت
اليوم لا تستطيع ان توقف لما الناس تسمع
هذه المجازر التي ترتكب في القصير وسيكتشف
الناس ليقوم بها جماعه من حزب الله وحتى
من القوميين السوريين وموجود قوميون
سوريون عندنا في الشمال لا نستطيع بذك ان
نضبط الناس ان تكون هناك فتنه طائفيه او
مذهبيه او شو ما بدك تسميها لذلك نحن
وجهنا الناس الى ان يكون واجبنا الدفاع عن
المظلومين عن المذبوحين عن المستضعفين بغض
النظر عن من يذبحهم سواء كان من شبيهه
الاسد او من حزب او من قوميين سوريين لا
نريد ان ننتقم او نحارب الحزب لانه من حزب
الله نريد ان ندافع عن هؤلاء المذبوحين
الذين سكت العالم العربي والغربي والكل عن
صرخاتهم وصيحات سي فيصل ربما يتباهى حزب
الله في اكثر او تبه في اكثر من مناسبه
تاريخيه في لبنان بانه يمارس اقصى درجات
ضبط النفس تجاه الفرقاء اللبنانيين هل
تعتقد ان حزب الله سيظل يتحلى بهذه
الممارسه اذاء تطورات الاوضاع ودعوات من
قبيل هذه الدعوه التي نناقشها
اليوم استاذ محمود دعني اذكر سماحه الشيخ
وهو مفترض يعني يتحلى بالحكمه والعقل وال
يعني والادراك الكافي اكثر مني واكثر من
غيري عندما يحاول يعني تلبيس القضيه هذا
اللبوس الطائفي والمذهبي على اعتبار انه
هب لنصره اخوانه السنه وان دعوات الجهاد
لديها مستدركات شرعيه انا اريد ان اسال
سماحه الشيخ اي المدارك الشرعيه هو دخل
اليها ويعني اصدرها مثل هذه الفتاوى
ولماذا لم تكن هذه الفتاوى تقوم عندما كان
اهلنا الفلسطينيون في غزه يقتلون بوابل من
الطائرات الامريكيه والاسرائيليه اين كان
كل هذا العالم العربي الذي يقول انه انتفض
لمواجهه المشروع الايراني والاجنه التي
يحاول حزب الله تنفيذها في المنطقه نعم
حاول ت ان يسال
ايض
اكمل الفكره استدراك استدراك بسيط فقط على
هذه الفكره هل يحق هل يحق مدام حزب الله
يعني كان يدافع او كما تريد ان توحي كان
يدافع عن الاطفال والنساء الذين يقتلون في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هل يحق له الدفاع في
هذه المنطقه او يحرم على اسرائيل ان تقتل
الاطفال والنساء الفلسطينيين ويحل للنظام
السوري ان يقتل الاطفال والنساء السوريين
ويحلوا لمن عاونوه سواء من حزب الله او من
غيره اقصد النظام السوري ان يقتلوا هؤلاء
الاطفال والنساء
السوريين لا احد يستطيع ان يحلل قتل
الاطفال والمدنيين ابتداء سواء كان
المعتدي من الجيش السوري او من ال
المعارضه السوريه او من السعودي او من
الايراني او من حزب الله هذا كلام معروف
على المستوى الشرعي لا يستطيع احد ان يحلل
ابتداء سفك الدماء نحن نتحدث عن صراع
مفتوح استاذ محمود ليس له علاقه بالمنطوق
المذهبي الا اذا كان البعض يحاول ان
يستثير الشعوب العربيه على قاعده مذهبه
الصراع نحن نقول ان الصراع في سوريا هو
صراع سياسي وان الجيش العربي السوري فيه
من العلويين وفيه من السنه وفيه من
المسيحيين وفيه من الدروز وفيه من
المرشديين وفيه من
الشيعه العتك ولكن بعد فاصل قصير ساعود
اليك مجددا ولكن بعد فاصل قصير نناقش بعده
فرص لبنان في تلافي الانجرار اكثر الى
الصراع في سوريا على ضوء التدخل الميداني
لمقاتلي حزب الله في فنرجو ان تبقوا معنا
مشاهدينا
الاعزاء اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الاعزاء
في هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر التي
تناقش مالات التدخل المدني لحزب الله
اللبناني في القتال الدائري في سوريا اعود
الى ضيفي من بيروت السيد فيصل عبد السات
سيد فيصل ابتداء هل تقر او هل يقر الفرقاء
في لبنان بان لحزب الله وجودا داخل
الاراضي السوريه ام لا ايا كانت مبررات
ودواعي هذا التدخل او هذا
الوجود اعود واكرر ليس هناك من وجود لحزب
الله بالمعنى التنظيمي والرسمي داخل سوريا
سوى في القرى والبلدات
التي يعني يسكنها لبنانيون من مختلف
الطوائف وهي تشكل امتدادا حيويا
واستراتيجيا لخزان المقاومه الستراتيجي في
منطقه البقاع الشمالي مدينه الهرمل ولذلك
الان الاعتداءات التي طاولت المدنيين في
مدينه الهرمل وبعض الكره المجاوره لها
انما جاءت لكي تنقل الازمه الى الداخل
اللبناني ولكي تغطي على الوقائع الميدانيه
ويقال ان حزب الله هو سبب الان انتصارات
في الداخل السوري لان الجيش العربي السوري
استطاع ان يعني يستعيد الكثير من القرى
والبلدات يسقط دعاوه كثيره جاءت في ثنايا
خطابات متعدده للسيد حسن نصر الله اشار
فيها الى ان سوريا المتماسكه بجيشها قادره
على تحقيق النصر في معركتها ضد
خصومها بطبيعه الحال ليس هناك من جيش
يستطيع ان يفرض سيطره كامله عندما تكون كل
الدنيا تحارب في داخل سوريا تحت عنوان
الجهاد وتحت عنوان نصره اهلنا في الشام
ونصره اهلنا في العراق وهذه الدعوات
الجهاديه التي يستجيب لها البلجيكي
والهولندي والفرنسي والقطري والسعودي
والاماراتي والليبي والتونسي في حين انه
لم نسمع اي دعوه للجهاد تنصر اهلنا في غزه
حتى يستطيعوا ان يفتحوا معبر غزه حتى
بوجود الاخوان المسلمين الذين وصلوا الى
الحكم في مصر لم يستطيعوا ف معبر رفح حتى
الان فكيف تستوي هنا دعوه للجهاد
والنص وهناك لا
تستو يعني معلومه مغلوطه المعبر مفتوح بين
غزه ومصر بشروط وضوابط كثيره ولم يعد
الامر كما هو
الحال محمود مشبه استاذ محمود دعني اطرح
السؤال على السيد او الشيخ سالم الرافعي
شيخ سالم هل هناك حاجه فعليه يعني نعيد
السؤال مره اخرى ه هناك حاجه فعليه لارسال
مقاتلين سنه من لبنان لنصره اخوانهم داخل
سوريا ام ان هذه رساله موجهه الى الداخل
اللبناني تريدون ان تقولوا باختصار نحن
نريد وضعيه مميزه في لبنان كوضع حزب الله
داخل الدوله
اللبنانيه اخي الكريم احب بس ان اجيب اخي
فيصل قليلا اخ فيصل اريد ان اقول لك اولا
كونكم لم تسمعوا عن دعوه منا لنصره اهلنا
في غزه لا يعني انها لم تقع اذا راجعتم
خطبنا في تلك الحقبه ستسمعون تلك الدعوه
وكانت دعوه واضحه وقويه الامر الاول الامر
الثاني اذا كان حزب الله دافع في فتره من
فترات عن اخ اخواننا الفلسطينيين مشكورا
لكن هذا لا يبرر ان يوغل في دم ويلق في دم
اخواننا السوريين الامر الثالث اذا كان
الدوله السوريه والجيش السوري كما تقول
ليس طائفيا لا يهمنا نحن الان كل الناس
ترى مجازر الجيش السوري في الناس في قتل
النساء واغتصابهن وقتل الاطفال والشيوخ
وسرخ الجلود نحن ندافع عن هؤلاء المظلومين
سواء كانوا سنه ام شيعه لبنانيين ام
سوريين او كانوا مسيحيين الاسلام اذا
سالتم عن الدليل الشرعي تعرضون بالدليل
الشرعي الاسلام امرنا ان ندافع عن
المظلومين من اي فئه كانوا النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول كيف يقدس الله امه لا يؤخذ
الحق فيها لضعيفها من قويه و السؤال فقط
يعني الجيش الحر السوري صاحب المكونات
السوريه بين ثنايا وحقق انتصارات وانجازات
على الارض داخل سوريا لماذا هذه الدعوه هل
هي موجهه الى الداخل اللبناني ام هي فعلا
لنصره السوريين والاجابه باختصار لو تكرمت
اخي الحقيقه جاءتنا استغاثات كثيره من
نساء من اخواتنا في القصير من اطفالهم من
شيوخهم من نسائهم هذا الامر سكت عن سمائه
العالم وسكت عن سمائه للاسف حكام العرب لا
نستطيع نحن ان نصم اذاننا سنسال عن ذلك
يوم القيامه واتمنى من الاخ فيصل لا يقف
امام الله يوم القيامه وهو يدافع عن
المجرم الذي قتل هؤلاء وسب النساء الشيخ
سالم الرافعي عضو هيئه علماء المسلمين او
نائب رئيس هيئه علماء المسلمين في لبنان
واشكر ضيفي من بيروت الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي فيصل للاسف للاسف سيد فيصل لم يعد
هناك متسع من الوقت مشاهدي الاعزاء بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
س